we've reviewed a lot of smaller more
compact headphones on this channel
lately now it's time for one of the
industry's best beats by dre studio
Wireless threes what's going on guys my
name is David Tommy and welcome back to
the channel today as I previously
mentioned we're reviewing the beats by
dre studio Wireless threes more
specifically we're reviewing the matte
black version of the wireless threes if
you guys love the matte black headphones
make sure you check out the link down
below to one of my companies called wire
watches we've recently launched a whole
collection of midnight black watches
that I know you guys are gonna love
alright so let's talk about these
headphones right here I've had these
headphones for just over a year now and
I used to use them every single day for
video editing work and sometimes going
to the gym as well to be perfectly
honest with you guys it's the second
pair of beats by dre as I've owned the
last couple years recently I just got
rid of my studio twos and upgraded to
the studio threes thinking that unlike
my studio twos I'd use them a lot more
and in fact I did when I first got these
headphones I use them all the time
but as time went on I stopped using them
as much and I think that's part of the
reason I'm making this review so if
you're in Australia like me you're
looking at paying about $450 for these
headphones full price at a store like JB
hi-fi you can pick them up for a little
bit cheaper when they're on sale but
they don't go on sale too often as they
are controlled by Apple this video isn't
sponsored anyway so it is completely my
genuine opinion about these headphones
over the time I've been using them I
loved them at the start they were great
and there was absolutely nothing wrong
with them the sound quality was
incredible the bass was so powerful and
just the clarity and the richness of the
tones was amazing it was definitely
worth the price I paid for them but over
time I actually stopped using them as
much I just started using the standard
desktop speakers that are hidden behind
the fake little plant there and these
things just kind of sat on my desk for a
while and I think one of the main
reasons for that was the fact when when
you put them on after a while being in
Australia it does get very hot now again
you started to sweat underneath the
cuffs and it got really
really irritating and the top of your
head started to get a little bit sore
and after editing for two three four
hours straight but these headphones kind
of got a little bit uncomfortable in my
personal opinion and that's why I found
it so much easier just to edit straight
from the desktop speakers yes I know I'm
compromising a little bit of sound
quality but for a peace of mind and
could just practicality and comfort that
was worth it for me one thing I found
that with these headphones is the little
leather ear cups do occasionally get a
little bit sweaty and stinky and gross
so with my studio twos that I mentioned
before I used to wear them to the gym
every single day and after a while well
the leather earpieces just kind of got
really stinking and gross so I had to go
online order a second pair replace the
little cuffs but they were never the
same so the end of the day I ended up
with $450 headphones that didn't feel
like a premium brand and smelt a little
bit not exactly ideal especially if
you're considering buying these
headphones for the gym or any other
physical exercise that you get a sweat
during there is one more little con
about these headphones and one of the
main reasons I did buy them was the fact
when I travel I usually put these big
headphones on because little in-ear ones
get really uncomfortable on a plane and
they start hurting my ears quite a lot
so I thought that if I buy these
headphones they're gonna be perfect for
travel and I'm gonna be able to throw my
backpack all the time and just not worry
about them I guess there's technology
advanced and things got better
the little Samsung buds for example
became my primary go-to headphones even
on plane trips now they aren't as
irritating and they're much better and
much more comfortable to wear then old
any headphones used to be so yeah
originally I thought I was gonna be able
to travel with these headphones and just
have them in my backpack all the time
but as my backpack got heavier with more
and more camera gear and different
accessories and different lenses the
space in my camera bag got less and less
and less so eventually these headphones
actually ended up staying in the
cupboard instead of coming with me
overseas unfortunately that was a big
shortfall for me and that's one of the
reasons I think I've decided to step
away from these headphones and move
forward into the brand
dancing buds that's just my personal
opinion and my personal choice for my
lifestyle because I believe they're more
practical and more powerful for me in an
everyday situation they're lugging these
things around from portability
perspective I've given you a bunch of
cons here but realistically these
headphones are still incredible pieces
of engineering and they do an a
magnificent job if you are in the market
for something like these don't be afraid
to actually go out and buy them I know
there has been a little bit of chatter
online about these headphones recently
predominantly about the fact that it's a
bit of an outdated design that's a
little bit big clunky and a little bit
chunky as well but firstly speaking from
somebody who studied architecture and
spends most of their day designing I
still genuinely love these headphones
I think the map that color is what gets
me from day dot when you see them in the
shops and when you see them in real life
there are completely different beasts to
anything out there the fact that they
have such a premium feel and aesthetic
to them really gets you over the line
now I know this is a superficial way of
thinking about a product and it's more
about the quality of the sound that it
puts out but the looks do play a part
when you're selecting your perfect
headphones even during the unboxing
experience they've really gone to the
details and made sure that matte or
matte black finish has been carried out
throughout the whole design so overall
what do I really think about these
headphones I think they're an amazing
set of headphones that are going to give
you that premium sound all rich base
that you're probably looking for if
you're checking out this video however I
do think they're a little bit chunky I
do think they're a little bit big and
not very practical and portable I do
think they're a little bit overpriced
and you're paying for that beats by dre
premium price tag which at the end of
the day for the sound quality producers
I do think it's justified they are very
durable headphones that I personally
believe are gonna last your lifetime if
you take care of them however if you're
planning on using these headphones to go
to the gym or do anything that's gonna
cause you to sweat whilst wearing them
you may have a few problems down the
track so make sure that if you are
sweating in them take them out of the
box when you get home clean them off let
them to air out and hopefully you won't
have the same problems I had before so
if you're looking for a pair of
headphones to sit on your desk and you
as a workhorse these are probably the
ones I would recommend however if you
are looking for something it's simply a
little bit more portable practical and
that you're gonna use every day I would
suggest that you take a look into
Samsung buds or the Apple earpods these
are the things that are going to get you
through the day in the most comfortable
and most convenient way possible for you
right now in 2019 and that's all I have
for you guys today the video was short
and sharp and I hope you enjoyed it and
make sure you smash that subscribe
button the channel is growing thank you
so much for being a part of it and as
always I'll see you next Monday for
another tech review or e-commerce
related adventure